que la campagne présidentielle dans
cette ferme géante du salon de
l'agriculture aujourd'hui c'est marine
le pen la candidate du rassemblement
national qui arpentait les allées fabien
becker avec sa vie à deux chiens
séance de celle fille pour marine le pen
au salon de l'agriculture
rattraper ces derniers jours par ses
positions pro poutine la candidate et
rennes peut néanmoins se réjouir elle
vient de réunir ses 500 parrainages pour
être candidate
[Musique]
dans les travées du salon marine le pen
se pose en défenseur des agriculteurs en
période de crise il faut mettre en place
maintenant le quoi qu'il en coûte pour
l'agriculture parce que pendant covin on
a fait le quoi qu'il en coûte mais les
agriculteurs ils ont pas vu requis en
coupe de bercy un salon de l'agriculture
inauguré samedi par emmanuel macron ils
devaient y passer la journée mais la
crise ukrainienne en a décidé autrement
une visite éclair le temps d'évoquer
avec les représentants de filières les
répercussions de la guerre sur le monde
agricole de manière certaine il y aura
des conséquences des conséquences dans
nos exportations
pour les grandes filières que vous
représentez malgré le contexte
international impossible pour les
candidats à l'elysée de ne pas honorer
ce rendez vous incontournable en période
de campagne de fabien roussel à valérie
pécresse tous promettent de lutter
contre la hausse des prix de l'énergie
et multiplient les appels à la
souveraineté alimentaire avec la crise
la ferme france
difficile pourtant pour ces candidats de
faire entendre leurs propositions
la guerre en ukraine menace d'étouffer
encore un peu plus une campagne
électorale déjà éclipsé par le cos vide
si nous passons à côté de cette élection
eh bien nous aurons une situation de
conflit social permanent à l'issue de
cette crise et de cette guerre en europe
on ne peut pas priver les françaises et
les français du choix qui doit être le
leur jeudi ce sera au tour de yannick
jadot de se rendre au chevet des
agriculteurs avant eric zemmour vendredi
qui parle à la france rurale comment
parler aux agriculteurs avec cette
guerre à 1000 km de paris voilà le thème
de notre premier débat avec jean
garrigues bonsoir jean garrigues on soit
en historien président du comité
d'histoire parlementaire vous publiez la
tentation du sauveur histoire d'une
passion française c'est aux éditions
payot nico louvre avant soir venu à vous
aussi vous êtes directrice des
rédactions du groupe réussir à agra
jacques a également alain chatriot
bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
professeur des universités à sciences po
historien auteur de la politique du blé
crise et régulation d'un marché dans la
france de l'entré deux guerres publié
par le comité pour l'histoire économique
et financière matthieu croissandeau
bonsoir mathieu on soit à mes côtés dans
cette chaude ambiance du du salon de
l'agriculture
je commence avec vous alain chatriot on
vient de voir les images des des
candidats pourquoi leur passage au salon
de l'agriculture elle est évidente ma
question ça reste un enjeu important
alors c'est un enjeu de campagne parce
que ça leur permet d'être visible
médiatiquement et ça leur permet aussi
de à la fois se confronter à des
questions qui sont des questions
importantes pour l'avenir la
souveraineté alimentaire les enjeux
environnementaux
mais ça permet aussi de se confronter
pas seulement aux producteurs mais à
l'ensemble du monde rural et de ce point
de vue là si le nombre d agriculteurs
professionnels des exploitants agricoles
ont très fortement diminué le poids
électoral de l'ensemble du monde rural
et de l'ensemble des personnes
impliquées dans les questions agricoles
et alimentaires restent considérables et
donc au moment d'une présidentielle mais
même lors des années qu'ils ne sont pas
des années à présidentielle c'est
toujours un moment de visibilité très
forte parce que le poids électoral n'est
pas qu'un poids simplement quantitatif
lié au nombre d'agriculteurs ou et puis
évidemment il ya une concentration c'est
à dire qu'on peut quasiment croiser tous
les métiers du secteur agricole en dans
un espace réduit même si même si le lieu
était est imposant nico louvre à vous
l'avez dit a de moins en moins
d'agriculteurs en france un premier
chiffre source ministère de
l'agriculture le nombre d'exploitations
a baissé de 21% en dix ans en est à un
peu moins de 390 milles et exploitation
mais effectivement le secteur pèse
encore beaucoup sur notre économie on
peut dire ça oui alors effectivement on
a perdu 100 mille agriculteurs en dix
ans donc effectivement c'est très
important
pour autant le monde agricole alors
leurs failles ça ce sont les
agriculteurs on va dire professionnels
en activité mais on a les retraités qui
compte aussi beaucoup on a aussi tous
les gens qui travaillent
dans le monde agricole les organisations
agricoles les industries
agroalimentaires on est quand même un
pays en france où le houleux
l'alimentation compte compte encore
beaucoup et tout cela fait 1 1 une
population qui a encore une sensibilité
autour de l'agriculture des enjeux
agricoles des enjeux de l'alimentation
et on relit tout ça à la ruralité
bien que en france il y ait de plus en
plus de gens qu'ils soient urbains les
campagnes sont habitées et les campagnes
ont encore une sensibilité à
l'agriculture donc effectivement le
passage au salon de l'agriculture
marc
cette sensibilité à l'agriculture et on
les voit tous des filets à chaque fois
villabon soit d'ailleurs en période
électorale ou pas oui mais ça prend un
peu plus d'importance en année
présidentielle évidemment jean garrigues
est ce que c'est toujours aussi
important qui à 27 ans l'année de la
première victoire de jacques chirac à la
présidentielle et je fais pas par hasard
référence à jacques chirac c'est vrai
que jacques chirac sa vait par les eaux
au monde rural il savait flatter le le
cul des vaches comme comme on le disait
à l'époque mais il ya une dimension de
toute façon symbolique et historique qui
est très profonde dans ce rendez vous
annuel qui d'ailleurs remonte au comice
agricole et aux années des débuts la
troisième république c'est un rituel
j'allais dire c'est un rituel
républicain ce rendez-vous de du salon
de l'agriculture oui les deux piliers
les deux piliers c'était le paysan et
l'instituteur quoi dans la construction
de l'imaginaire de ces résume les
quelque chose de très fort qui échappe
même à à 7 reste réduction du périmètre
économique et social du monde du monde
agricole et on voit bien d'ailleurs dans
le dernier quinquennat à quel point ces
questionnements sur le lien entre le
pouvoir leurs centrales et les
territoires a été un des questionnements
majeurs de la du quinquennat macron donc
c'est ça reste quelque chose qui était
essentielle et donc qui nécessite
justement une visibilité une présence
des des hommes politiques et je le
répète la dimension symbolique est très
très forte beaucoup plus forte qu'en
qu'on ne pourrait l'imaginer ou alors
c'est pas si c'est vrai aujourd'hui mais
on peut être élu réélu sans forcément
venir souvent au salon de l'agriculture
si je ne me trompe françois mitterrand
et très peu venu au salon de
l'agriculture françois mitterrand
considéré que cette au ministre de
l'agriculture
venir au salon mais françois mitterrand
avait un rapport en tout cas
apparaissait comme ayant un rapport
justement très très direct avec les
territoires ce qui n'est pas forcément
le cas de certains de ses successeurs on
se souvient de nicolas sarkozy des
problèmes qu'il a rencontrés au salon et
et de l'image qui est celle d' emmanuel
macron par exemple ça veut dire que
l'enjeu il est il est très symbolique
très politique très historique mathieu
oui parce que comme le disait jean on y
croise des agriculteurs bien sûr on y
croise aussi des représentants de tout
le territoire bien sûr tous les
départements des élus et puis si c'est
une épreuve personnelle pour les
candidats faut lire parce que ça révèle
quelque chose de même le renard culturel
leur capacité à répondre leurs capacités
aussi à se confronter parfois parce que
c'est pas toujours facile les visites au
salon de l'agriculture quand il ya de la
colère quand y'a de la détresse et puis
vous pouvez être interpellé à la fois
par les agriculteurs mais aussi par le
public est ainsi que parfois ça fait des
étincelles genre il faisait allusion le
fameux casse toi pauvre con de nicolas
sarkozy qui a été prononcé ici la
dernière fois emmanuel macron s'est pris
1,9 françois hollande s'est est pris
aussi des écrits de colère des crachins
parfois donc voilà il faut il faut
savoir quand on est politique se
confronter à cette réalité mais alors ce
trio alors c'était pas le cas cette
année puisque emmanuel macron à cause de
la guerre en ukraine est resté deux
heures mais il ya en plus une espèce de
surenchère depuis quelques années à
celui qui reste le plus longtemps oui
alors ça c'est beaucoup pour les images
est effectivement pour le relais
médiatiques cherche souvent aussi les
petites phrases et c'est vrai que le
salon a pu donner lieu à quelques
petites phrases hélas mémorable mais il
n'ya pas que cette dimension là il ya
bien sûr cet enjeu symbolique cet enjeu
de relais médiatiques en particulier en
campagne mais il ya aussi une autre
dimension majeure qui est pour les
équipes des candidats c'est aussi un
moment de confrontation à l'ensemble des
acteurs du monde agricole et rural et de
ce point de vue là il faudrait pas ne
pensez que aux images à côté en
particulier des
bovidés qui souvent l'image c'est à dire
ça veut dire qu'à de l'info qui remonte
il ya des revendications qui rogne à
ilan a pris de la confrontation parfois
pas simple mais il ya des vrais
confrontation parce que il faut toujours
se rappeler qu'il ya aussi dans la
confrontation monde agricole tout un
enjeu de politique publique à l'échelon
national à l'échelon aussi européen et
international et donc pour les équipes
de campagne c'est aussi des moments de
rencontres de confrontation avec le
monde syndical mais pas seulement un mot
là-dessus nicolau ah oui en fait ça se
prépare tout c'est tout c'est venu au
salon se prépare c'est à dire que ils
passent ils savent qui dans quel stand
ils doivent passer où ils déambulent pas
au hasard exactement et dans quasiment
tous les salons il ya des petits salons
privés en fait derrière les lélés les
android et est donc il ya des moments
privilégiés pour parler avec chacune des
interprofessions avec chacun des des
responsables donc en un temps record il
ya une discussion très constructive très
efficace qui est organisé et et ça que
ce soit ben pour la fin pour tous les
candidats
alors une question centrale que mathieu
aussi vieille que le sol riche dur y at
il à un vote paysan comment votent les
agriculteurs mais on en a dit un mot
déjà c'est difficile de répondre à cette
question parce qu'ils sont pas très
nombreux agriculteurs quand on prend ne
serait ce que pour faire des
échantillons des sondages quand vous
avez une population d'agriculteurs
exploitants de 400000 à peu près selon
selon les chiffres de l'insee c'est un
peu compliqué alors je dis 400 milles
c'est vrai que ça a beaucoup baissé on
l'a dit depuis 40 ans mais on peut y
ajouter évidemment toutes les familles
tous les gens qui qui qui côtoie
l'agriculture de prêts y compris par
exemple les 250 quelque 250 mille
ouvriers agricoles mais que l'insee ne
range pas dans la catégorie
d'agriculteurs mais dans la catégorie
des ouvriers par exemple donc on voit
que c'est un peu différent en gros quand
on demande aux agriculteurs comment il
se positionne même si on est de gauche
droite mais il se place
traditionnellement sous la vème
république et même avant à droite et au
centre droit selon la dernière édition
du baromètre agricole terre-net data
grille en décembre dernier
ils étaient seulement six pour cent ans
classé à gauche pour cent se classer à
l'extrême gauche et tout le reste était
au centre 30% à droite 46% et à
l'extrême droite 16% c'est donc un
échiquier politique très déformée par
rapport au reste de la population après
est-ce que ce fort tropisme à droite
induit un vote pour l'extrême droite
c'est quelque chose qui avait été craint
et redouté ou espérés par d'autres mais
en 2017 on disait alors que marine le
pen ferait des très gros scores ça n'a
pas été vérifiée dans les urnes là selon
la grande étude ipsos pour le monde
quand on regarde un peu comment votent
les agriculteurs ils disent leur langue
l'intention de voter pour emmanuel
macron et pour eric zemmour et pas du
tout pour marine le pen en voile et elle
et elle est loin derrière et et valérie
pécresse dans tout ça alors valérie
pécresse son plaisir c'est naturel parce
que la droite généralement le candidat
droite faisait 60 % du vote des
agriculteurs mais c'est pas forcément a
préféré selon le même baromètre dont je
vous parlais celui terre-net bourg data
grille valérie pécresse était pas du
tout par exemple dans la primaire
républicaine a préféré et puis il ya une
certitude en tout cas c'est que beaucoup
d'entre eux des agriculteurs ont été
déçus par le quinquennat d'emmanuel
macron un petit tiers considèrent qu'il
a tenu ses engagements à moitié
seulement un autre petit tiers qui les a
assez peu tenu et pour un plus d'un
quart pas du tout oui on l'a évoqué
rapidement avec jean garrigues le
président sortant qui a un petit souci
avec les agriculteurs
il paye son image de président des
villes parce qu'on sait qu'il a été
notamment très plutôt bien élu dans les
centres urbains et puis il a eu beau
multiplier les déplacements clamé son
amour du terroir il reste avant tout
pour beaucoup un ancien banquier
d'affaires en costume et urbain bref le
portrait qu'en fait traditionnellement
la droite celui d'un président d'élite
monde est mondialisée s'enracine vous
savez on lui reproche souvent de ne pas
avoir la tâche au terroir c'est
d'ailleurs assez ridicule parce que il
fils à papa - d'attache que les autres
il vient d'un terroir particulier qu'est
la picardie mais depuis la crise des
religions en particulier s'est saisi du
dossier sous l'angle de la ruralité plus
que ses os ou lente de l'agriculture
d'ailleurs il a confié le ministère un
de ses plus fidèles julien de normandie
tellement fidèle d'ailleurs qu'il
pourrait bientôt être remplacé j'ai bien
demandé à ce que à la faveur d'un
remaniement le temps de la campagne
électorale pas sûr que ce changement de
tête du coup de dernière minute soit
particulièrement apprécié oui
effectivement c'est pas forcément le
meilleur moment nicolau voir ça vous
ferait ça vous allez réagir oui tout à
fait alors au niveau je vais préciser
quelques éléments concernant le les le
vote des agriculteurs donc il ya une
enquête effectivement vous en parliez
ipsos
cevipof dans lequel de 13000 personnes
dont il y avait un échantillon de 150
chefs d'exploitation et donc ça c'était
début février alors les choses ont pu
changer depuis début février on était à
emmanuel macron 29% donc
et
effectivement 24% mélenchon 13%
marine le pen dix pour cent des 13 7%
effectivement cessé on est vraiment sur
un recul de la droite classique qui qui
est surprenant mais bon voilà on peut
aussi se dire que les choses vont bouger
des conditions qu'ils aillent voter
parce que cette même montré
plutôt des gens qui votent les gens
aiment et dans cette enquête on est en a
on a vu la même un mathieu ipsos auprès
steria pour le monde et c'est hip hop 45
% des agriculteurs se disent certains
d'aller voter c'est 20 points de moins
que la moyenne et c'est surtout 20
points de moins par rapport à 2010 est
alors né à 40 jours à moins de 40 jours
donc ça peut évidemment encore évoluer
mais pour l'instant il ya
potentiellement un forum intentionnistes
cette déception autour de la droite doit
sans doute expliquer le fait qu'ils
aient
désaffection du ve est en fait
simplement et jean garrigues peut-être
aussi une déception vis-à-vis du
président de la république c'est ce
qu'on évoquait tout à l'heure oui
certainement mieux moi ce qui me frappe
justement à traverser ces résultats qui
sont quand même inédit c'est précisément
que la l'exceptionnalité du vote rural
est en train de se de s'éroder je dire
que c'est un vote qui peut se rapprocher
du vote global des français à la fois
dans ce rejet généralisé de la classe
politique dans son ensemble qui va les
conduire peut être être plus
abstentionniste qu'il ne l'était
auparavant dans cette érosion de la
candidate valérie pécresse dont on sait
que manifestement sa campagne peine à
apprendre et ça c'est quand même quelque
chose de nouveau parce que comme vous
l'avez dit le vote pour la droite
modérée c'est quand même une constante
sous la vème république c'était quelque
chose d'important pour dans le monde
dans le monde rural et puis voir
apparaître un à eric zemmour ça veut
dire une sensibilité plus importante au
sujet
on appelle régalien la sécurité
l'identité et ce sont des choses qui qui
rapproche finalement le monde rural de
la généralité de la globalité du vote du
vote des français c'est intéressant
parce que on se disait que ce vote garde
est justement une spécificité quelque
chose de très original et là moi je
trouve que on se rapproche un tout petit
peu de ce qu'elle à la sensibilité
française sous ce sous ce quinquennat
alors je vous donne la parole avec avec
une question vous pouvez répondre un peu
après mais est-ce que les néo ruraux
nantes en parle beaucoup notamment avec
l'effet de la crise sanitaire ça peut
changer la sociologie du vote
dans les campagnes françaises alain
chatriot alors dans certains endroits
oui mais je ne suis pas sûr qu'en
données agrégées au moment de la
présidentielle ça soit le phénomène le
plus massif et mais par contre ce kit ce
sur quoi il faut insister c'est aussi la
diversité du monde agricole
d'aujourd'hui qui oblige à distinguer
des secteurs du monde agricole qui
économiquement
fonctionne et se porte plutôt bien pour
le dire trop rapidement et d'autres dont
la crise dans à s'accentuer et donc
évidemment les comportements politiques
y compris des comportements
d'abstentions ou de vote aux extrêmes
qui était historiquement plutôt rare
s'accentue aussi dans ces franges là me
semble-t-il l'autre élément que je
voulais compléter séoul avait en partie
dit mais la déception éventuelle d'une
partie du monde agricole par rapport au
quinquennat qui s'achève
c'est pas seulement l'effet des
représentations même si celle ci joue un
rôle dans la vie politique c'est aussi
la confrontation à ce qui avait été pas
seulement une promesse mais un enjeu
majeur qu'étaient les états généraux sur
l'alimentation et qui ont donné lieu à
la loi et gally main puis la loi et
galine 2 et de ce point de vue la sarre
questionne la capacité des politiques
aujourd'hui à l'échelle française de
réussir à mener à bien des politiques
publiques qui touchent directement des
questions majeures que soit sa race que
ça soit celle du revenu des agriculteurs
d'un côté ou celle de la qualité des
produits alimentaires distribués à
l'ensemble de la population alors
justement les les rémunérations les
salaires des des agriculteurs je voulais
donner un chiffre d'abord sur le nombre
d'emplois alors on est sur les emplois
globaux ça rejoint ce que vous disiez
tout à l'heure dans l'agriculture on
parle de 760 1000 emplois en baisse de
12% par rapport à 2010
nicolau ouvrard les ya je crois un
ménage agricole sur cinq est sous le
seuil de pauvreté en france
aujourd'hui comment évolue finalement la
rémunération des agriculteurs en ce
moment alors il faut toujours faire
attention quand on parle de rémunération
des agriculteurs
il ya des chiffres qui ont été qui ont
été lancés
quand on parlait de redire notre 2 300
euros par mois on ne parle pas enfin
quand il faut pas le lier à un salaire à
ne faut pas le comparer à un salaire on
va dire parce qu'effectivement
l'agriculture l'exploitation agricole
peut vivre et et ne pas se rémunérer et
pour autant pouvoir vivre de son métier
mais il faut faire attention parce que j
fruits mais malgré tout ce qu'on s'ouvre
y semant
des secteurs agricoles comme vous disiez
on a des secteurs agricoles qui sont
vraiment en difficulté le le secteur
agricole le plus en difficulté c'est
l'élevage bovin viande ou là on a des
grandes difficultés profondes régulière
et effectivement cette question de la
répartition de la valeur sur la toute la
chaîne est et profonde est vraiment
profonde on a peu d'intérêt fin
d'interlocuteurs tout peu de
transformateurs et puis des agriculteurs
qui n'ont plus de pouvoir sur les prix
et ça c'est un vrai problème alors
effectivement
donc voilà les viticulteurs ils ont il
ya eu ils ont connu des grandes
difficultés aujourd'hui ça va mieux les
céréales c'est pareil dans les années
2000 grosses difficultés aujourd'hui ça
va mieux mais on est sur une fragilité
parce qu'il ya les les aléas climatiques
certaines années se suivent avec des
aléas climatiques différents mais
systématique autour des on a eu des
inondations on a eu des sécheresses donc
en fait on est sur des exploitations qui
sont fragilisés économiquement parce qu
en insécurité et là en fait c'est ça
cette difficulté il faut organiser prêt
à organiser une certaine sécurité
par l'assurance par
en fait les prix ou une organisation sur
la comment la rémunération ou des
contractualisation pluriannuelle
ce sont les objectifs les galim de alors
je vais prendre la main parce que ça
nous ramène alors ce sera le thème de
notre second débat tout à l'heure alain
chatriot mais j'aurais quand même vous
entendre sur la question de du du blé de
l'impact de cette de cette guerre en
ukraine sur sur la situation
des agriculteurs de certains céréaliers
je ne sais pas quel peut être l'impact
sur sur les agriculteurs français par
exemple il y avait question du double et
il ya la question des engrais aussi on
est on est à relativement dépendant des
engrais qui viennent de l'étranger c'est
un impact contradictoire si on les
regarde en ce moment en pleine guerre
d'invasion de l'ukraine par la russie
parce que les cours mondiaux ont
tendance à s'apprécier et 9 point de vue
là la production de céréales en france
est un des points forts de l'agriculture
française a eu tendance à s'accentuer
mais dans le même temps ce cours très
élevé des céréales va poser un problème
pour les autres parties du monde
agricole mais dont le surcoût va devenir
un vrai danger premiers éléments
deuxième élément vous venez de le dire
effectivement il ya la question des
carburants et de la production des
engrais et là on a une dimension où
l'équilibré économique d'un certain
nombre d'exploitations va peut-être être
mis en cause mais ce qu'il faut rappeler
ici et la crise géopolitique le montre
bien c'est que les équilibres ne se
situe pas qu'à l'échelle nationale ils
sont bien à l'échelle mondiale et avec
le relais mais qu a souvent été utilisée
comme un bouc émissaire en france qu'est
celui de la politique agricole commune
là aussi les discours des politiques le
plus souvent en ont fait un bouc
émissaire facile plutôt que de regarder
de près ce qui était négocié à bruxelles
entre tous les partenaires ont je me
développe pas trop cette partie parce
qu'encore une fois ce sera le thème de
notre second débat mais on a entendu je
vous donne la parole jean garrigues là
dessus tout à l'heure dans le reportage
d'ouverture de notre émission marine le
pen qui était dans les allées du salon
il ya il ya quelques heures dire on n'a
pas vu le coup elle est cool quoi qu'il
en dise on pas vu le quoi qu'il en coûte
de bercy les les agriculteurs ça ça vous
et tickets
quand pendant la diffusion du sujet ça
fait partie de ces petites phrases
polémiques qui font le sel de la vie
publique je pense que les agriculteurs
comme les autres ont bénéficié quand il
le fallait des des subventions qui était
nécessité par la crise du coc vide
maintenant qu'il y ait de la part du
monde rural le sentiment d'un relatif
abandon d'une déconnexion vis-à-vis des
élites urbaines ça ça reste quelque
chose de très profond c'est c'est
quelque chose qui est en partie
irrationnel mais qui s'adosse aussi sur
un aspect très trek comment dirais-je
très général de l'évolution de notre
société c'est à dire le creusement des
inégalités veut dire qu'entre 1 grands
céréaliers de du bassin parisien et le
petit éleveur de de lozère les
inégalités se sont certainement accrue
comme elles s'accroissent est dans
l'ensemble de la population française
donc on est là dans des des prises de
conscience dans des dans des attitudes
dans des comportements si vous voulez
qui se cristallise et on parler
d'insécurité je voulais rebondir là
dessus parce que cette insécurité
sociale et économistes elles se
cristallisent comme ailleurs dans la
population sur un phénomène d'insécurité
je dirais identitaire et se cristallise
sur phénomène d'immigration le ressenti
d'une immigration trop importante et c
est ça vous explique pourquoi notamment
le vote eric zemmour qui a pris en
compte vous savez il y avait cette
fameuse mesure sur les le lait les
subventions pour des familles nombreuses
en fin des paysans qu'ils aient beaucoup
d'enfants eric zemmour il a senti que du
côté de ceux de ce ce bloc paysans il y
avait éventuellement quelque chose à
jouer nicolet war sur le quoi qu'il en
coûte est-ce que ça en partie bénéficié
quand même au aux agriculteurs français
alors il fait ce qu'est ce qui peut
justifier cette phrase de marine le pen
il faut quand même reconnaître que le
secteur agricole a été moins touchée
dans cette risque au vide que bien
d'autres secteurs économiques parce que
les gens ont continué à manger un don
qu'il ya eu cette panique au démarrage
folle avec des achats complètement
irrationnel mais ensuite les choses se
sont organisés on a plutôt vu une re
enfin un recentrage sur l'alimentation
de la part de la de la population
française d'ailleurs il en reste quelque
chose c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui tous
les politiques développe l'idée de la
souveraineté alimentaire et ça c'est un
marqueur fort de cette campagne
politique et c'est plutôt positif pour
le secteur agricole après on a vu des
choses enfin intéressant c'est à dire
par exemple on a vu voir on a vu le bio
se développer très fortement aujourd'hui
est bien le bio est en recul de
consommation oui parce que les
consommateurs privilégient plutôt et
circuits courts et c'est l'inde est l'un
des aspects notamment de la gt salutaire
en fait on ne sait pas trop pourquoi
aujourd'hui la consommation
alors que le bio a été portée le local a
été porté pendant toute cette période de
colline aujourd'hui les gens retournent
au supermarché si je peux le dire aussi
simplement que ça ils achètent aussi sur
sur internet et du coup le bio le local
est plutôt en recul avec des inquiétudes
quoi donc voyez c'est complexe c'est
loin d'être aussi linéaire que ça moi je
pense qu'on peut pas dire que qui que le
quoi qu'il en coûte n'est pas concerné
le meut le monde agricole fin je crois
pas merci beaucoup merci à tous les
trois d'avoir participé à ce
premier débat